it's like a bad dream you know it it's
still up and down you know my emotions
you know it I'm trying not to process it
I'm trying to ignore the fact that it is
true it's a sad day here at Prince's
Paisley Park studios in autopsy got
underway this morning but of course the
big question is what was the cause of
death well here's what we've learned a
source very close to the situation tells
ET Prince had the flu that turned into
walking pneumonia
he was also dealing with a hip injury
and had a problem with the painkiller
percocet
we are told his issue with this very
powerful narcotic dates back years there
have been reports that maybe there was a
problem with painkillers and that maybe
in the days before his death there had
been an OD I just heard it on the news
that's all that I know and where as of
right now they're just rumors like yeah
do you know he was was he having trouble
with his hip still I did a long time ago
yeah yeah um I mean you think about all
the years that he was jumping off those
risers I mean they were they were not
low they were very very high and to jump
off of that oh he had those heels on for
that just an entire year would have
messed up his knees and then him doing
the splits I you know he was in pain all
the time he's you know but he was a
performer no one not even him would have
known that that would bother him years
later
their plans being made for a service is
it going to be here yet all that is
being done I think about some of the
lyrics of his of his songs did you ever
have conversations about how he felt the
you know mortality and and what we were
in this world in the afterlife and what
he believed his beliefs were different
than what they are now and that's part
of changed part of growing part of
searching did he find his purpose you
know um you know what does he believe in
or what does he not believe in he went
through all of that have you thought
about how you're gonna say goodbye
I don't know if I can